uh so we were talking a little bit
monique about
the ascension of podcasting we can all
sit here
and spend 15 20 minutes talking about
this issue of journalism and we'll talk
about four more five more issues in this
great episode
and i can't misquote you here you speak
for yourself
people can see the look on your face
when you say something they can hear the
context
when you say something to the press you
can say something
like you know this isn't really
important but
certainly you know x factor comes into
play here
and they can take that cut out this
really isn't the important point
and just take whatever you said and put
that in the headline
as the lead to the you know as the
headline or the link betting or whatever
is podcasting the future of all this you
think and in subjects you kind of
alluded to this that we're kind of
routing around
like i don't go to the press anymore i
am the press i i have 25 million
listeners a year i don't need to be on
anybody else's podcast i don't need to
talk to any journalist ever
if why would i talk to a journalist i
have something to say say it here
audience comes to direct can't
misinterpret me is this the future
uh it's not just podcasting it's
podcasting it's sub stack
having your own newsletter um
controlling your own email list and
being able to control your voice and
what you put out into the world
right um so podcasting is certainly part
of that
and definitely gives people who either
didn't have a voice
or felt that they were they were
misrepresented in some way
a voice that they can control right so i
think you know
the rise of podcast obviously obviously
started with like voice as a platform
and having
you know these devices in our home right
so that was like the first foray
and then we started layering podcasting
on top of that
uh and i think it will continue i think
people want to
control the way that they are seen by by
the public
right and people want to be able to
control what they put out into the
public
and i highly recommend to founders to
anyone
um you know in the industry control your
message
don't let the media control the message
for you right
right and do it either by writing
regularly
podcasting regularly or some piece of
content that you were able to like get
out there into the world yeah you gotta
develop that muscle as a founder because
you will get spun
i mean look what's happening to lambda
school right now i think that might be
in the notes coming up but
you know they're getting savaged online
and
luckily the kid austin who runs that
who's been on the pod he uh
he's coming back on the pod to talk
about it and these journalists are never
going to be able to talk to him
you know who's going to be able to talk
to him me because i'm not going to try
to like
do gotcha journalism with her i'm not
going to like have him come on in the
first five minutes just grill him i'm
gonna say hey tell me what's going on
how's the business
tell me honestly and that's why our
podcast is bigger than any journalist
podcast intact like we're gonna be just
much bigger than
the journalists because we're gonna get
better guests because they feel more
comfortable
having a real conversation here you
listen to a lot of podcasts with
uh i've started to listen to more
getting into it yeah starting to get
into it yeah we started sponsoring stuff
i'm like all right i got to understand i
got it
yeah yeah um you have any you like yeah
uh well reply all is the place i started
because yeah those guys do really good
it's like fun quirky like interesting
it's weird yeah cool stuff
yeah so people like that one yep i like
to listen to
the people who are the most polarizing
on each side and i like to listen to
them back to back
sometimes on my drive home i'll listen
to
rachel mata and ben shapiro
and they'll talk about the same stories
every day yeah and one of them
is talking about bernie sanders in one
way one the other and then when they
sync up is when it gets really
interesting
because they might say it slightly
differently but they're both a bit
worried about bernie sanders not
be you know ben shapiro's like bernie
sanders can't be trump he's gonna just
be like 40 people are
the trumps could take 40 states and
racial matters saying the same thing
like we better be careful what's going
on here we're not going to get trump out
with
bernie sanders they were like in sync on
that actual
issue